all right guys
bang bang i have a very very special
treat for you today
i have dan here thank you so much for
doing this sir
hey pom happy to be here finally
absolutely let's jump in real quick uh
give us kind of a quick overview of your
background and then we will get to the
conversation that everyone wants to hear
which is
gold and bitcoin okay um
well you know i've been through this a
few times already i think most people
know a little bit about my background i
was in the hedge fund business for 25
years as a global macro
uh pm um worked uh early
in my career with julian roberts in a
tiger and then michael steinhardt
um also then a little later on worked
with steve cohen at stack for 10 years
and then stan druckenmiller duquesne
and then back with steve again along the
way
uh focused on just about everything
outside of
uh specific uh equities um
you know that would be commodities and
currencies
uh emerging markets etc in 06 when i was
working with druck we launched
i was very focused on agriculture then
uh we
we launched a company called agcoa which
ended up becoming the largest private
farmland reit in the u.s
we sold it in 2013 to the canadian
pension fund system but for seven years
uh we built up this um
portfolio of farms out in
wheat corn soy producing farms out in
the midwest mostly
in the mississippi delta and in nebraska
so that was you know that was a case
where i took a macro
idea that i focused on for the portfolio
through positions in in grains and then
applied that idea to starting a business
uh did the same thing in 0809 with
physical gold
uh had been trading gold in the 90s or
positioning
um and then got very bullish in 08
worried about
you know banking systemic risk wanted to
hone some physical gold
outside of the banking system i mean to
have it stored outside the banking
system couldn't find a really
i would say legit triple a you know way
to do it you know you had guys on the
internet
uh i've said sort of like crazy eddie
type guys selling you
physical gold or you had guys you know
with a p.o box and the caymans
so um set out with a partner to start a
company called gold bullion
international
uh my partner there still the ceo uh
today
it's 11 years later the business is uh
really flourishing this year
uh it's just been a great business um
over over 40 people we've done
we've we have over 300 000 clients uh
done over a million trades and we're the
third largest vaulter now
gold out in the world outside of the max
and so i really know the physical gold
business
uh i i i you know i sometimes
it takes a lot for me to sort of hold
back especially on twitter we'll get
into this little later because
i am coming from a different place of
knowledge i mean i
i know this business anyway so um
and then uh in 2014
that gold business integrated with bit
reserve which today is the uphold wallet
and we were the first place that you
could buy and sell physical gold to buy
and sell bitcoin and ripple
so that was sort of my intro into uh
the bitcoin world uh and then in 2019
uh the company partnered with equity
trust to offer an ira
and we were the second place in the us
where you could trade eight different
cryptocurrencies
um in your ira and we also partnered
with dcg
uh i've known barry you know eight years
or so on on the other
side so we built that platform dcg of
course doing the execution and equity
trust
in the you know facing the client but we
were the ones who
sort of built that architecture so that
pulled me
more into the world and then in q1 q219
what happened was you know the price had
collapsed
from uh 19 down to four and as a macro
guy
look you know that either it's a bust
right after a blow-off or it was a big
opportunity and i had
been making little bits of money in it
not a lot
um and then i just sort of i did the
whole rabbit hole thing i
i said this is the time i did six months
really of
uh 10 hours a day of reading podcasts i
you know re everything just totally
immersive
and it sort of resulted in that
interview i did with raul powell last
summer
about bitcoin and that was sort of like
my kind of
entry into the world i mean i i didn't
even do
twitter at that point and raul says to
me dan just give me
a twitter account and like people will
follow up with questions and
so i just i'd had an account that i'd
set up but i never used it didn't know
how to use it
anyway i that was sort of my uh sort of
entry uh into the into this world and
you know of course as you know the
entire bitcoin world lives on twitter i
tell people
it's not new york it's not silicon
valley it's not hong kong
it's it lives on twitter and of course
because it lives on twitter we know
you are one of the guys uh
i don't know not gatekeepers per se but
you're one of the
you know i just think keep key people in
the space you connect
so many different people and i i'm
thrilled to be here and i know we've
been trying to do it for
for about a year just because i i guess
in a way i think you reflect the
zeitgeist
that's how i i see it from like uh you
know
from the top down like if people say to
me who are five people i have to
follow or who whose daily piece that you
write
uh you're definitely the hardest man
hardest working man
in bitcoin there's no blockchain
cryptocurrency whatever you call it
i don't think anybody would dispute that
i appreciate the kind
words and uh for those that don't know
uh
in march and april of this year when all
of the economic chaos was kind of going
on and there's lots of uncertainty
uh you were one of a very select few
number of people that basically i was
like
begging to get on the phone i was like
help me understand what is going on
right now
and uh and you nailed it man you uh you
were all over it and so uh that
experience definitely paid off yeah that
was
you know what that was really fun
because look when you've been in the
markets for 30 years
you're used to you know selling climaxes
and panics and this and that
and you see it in different places
around the world and march was really
bad
but i can remember that one day in march
when it gapped down
the bitcoin debt down through like six
five it was six and then five
and i started getting all of these
messages from all these people that like
dan
you were so wrong you don't know
anything and i put this tweet out like
listen
it's the only time and i'm against the
person on twitter just because i
you know you gotta but it was the only
time on twitter i said
what did i said stfu
right this is like the bot this
is like this is the only really truly
freely trading market
basically this is it right like this is
the bottom this is not
you know i was getting bombarded all
over the place
and you know i i just um
nothing really had changed you know
anyway it was
it was a great moment to be involved in
and then in the weeks
after i mean you and i did talk a lot
about the dollar
um because that was the high and that
was part of what we were talking about
was that um
the federal reserve would sacrifice the
dollar before the equity market
and the asset market and so that was
another
um meaning they would have preferred the
dollar they would let the dollar go down
as much as they needed to as long as it
ended up supporting the equity market
right so
um yeah that was a very exciting time
and i think a lot of guys in this space
uh sort of became more macro after that
right
absolutely yeah let's start the
conversation just around gold and
bitcoin with
how do you right now if you know one of
your global macro
uh friends called you up and they said
uh look
we i want to understand this dan like
how would you describe your thesis
on gold and your thesis on bitcoin to
them
yeah well you know the macro guys for
the most part
know why and how to uh execute and
position in gold and
you know you saw tudor jones's letter
this summer which was uh i think
you know one of the two or three most
important uh
events in the space uh you know he had a
he has a significant position in gold
um you know and you can read his
eight-page paper which i think is is
pretty good gives you good sense
and then of course druck uh as well came
out a few days ago and and
and mentioned a position in gold uh
and so that really doesn't need so much
explanati explaining people get
that look the the balance sheets of uh
central banks have been exploding uh you
know m2
is up 25 year-over-year and you know
it's really
not been up over 10 in any period rates
are zero globally
there's huge injections of liquidity
going on
by all the major central banks so i
don't that's not really
you know that doesn't really need
explanation i think
it's a little more uh it's a little more
difficult to explain bitcoin
because um to own gold
is to own uh you know is to
is to be short fiat right and so there's
also this
paper hard asset dichotomy which really
resonates with
sort of more traditional uh in
investment managers meaning
they get this paper they get there's an
unlimited amount of paper
right or there will be and that there's
more or less a finite amount of gold
and that it's hard you can hold it you
know with one percent a year increase in
supply or whatever
it's versus all the other assets out
there
in the world it's finite right and i
know the bitcoiners are constantly
saying off
gold it's not finite you can find it in
the the asteroid or
whatever insanity that you want to come
up with but more or less and
and i want to get into this because uh
even though
uh i do have great respect for your work
uh i do
think that the piece that you wrote a
few days ago
uh sort of really inspired this and and
we've talked about this a bit before the
show
gold versus bitcoin doesn't end in
coexistence
and it's something that you know i
really don't believe that's
true and i think one of the themes if
there if you'd say there's one
theme that's consistent that i can
continue to put out on twitter
is that you really have to own both and
i want to clarify that though because
and well and that's because
look there's no question that bitcoin
is going to outperform gold so i think
people should stop
talking on twitter about it's bad
you're saying specifically uh that
bitcoin from like a price appreciation
price appreciation it is the fastest
horse it will be the fastest horse
we can you could spend hours explaining
why but
i just or or not um i think it's
um and and the way i think about it is
in the next
sort of five years i could see gold at 4
000
so that's a double but if gold's at 4
000
bitcoin is probably somewhere between
300 and 500 000
so that's a 20 30 x well it was from
last week it's still i mean it's about a
20
20 30 x and so i don't
really think that that anyone in the
gold world
even who you know even tudor jones is
he's his fastest horse
they're not going to debate that so i
don't you know i don't
you know i so and if you're a little if
you're a small investor
um you know you may you may say well i
don't need gold i just want the one
that's going to perform uh the best over
a bunch of years okay
but gold has certain characteristic
characteristics and
traits today that i don't
think i'm not sure people are are aware
of
and like so why why bother with gold at
all you use the
blockbuster and netflix analogy
right and i think that's actually the
wrong analogy
because you and also and sailor too by
the way who i
loved to death but um you know you come
from a technologist background
right and so you look at it and you say
bitcoin is new technology
gold is old technology okay so
there is some truth to that there is
some truth to that
but that's not that's not why gold is
important today
or why it will be in the future so
um okay so what is
you know what is uh what's important
about
let's hold on let's start with gold
itself right
in terms of like why is gold important
today right so one of the things is
um gold is tremendous liquidity right
it's an 11 trillion
and 12 trillion dollar uh total market
value
bitcoin is still only 350 billion so
if you are an institution let's say
you're the as an example this norwegian
oil fund
they have a trillion dollars they want
to put five percent to work
uh in let's say a non-fiat
asset that is scarce okay
they can't do bitcoin they can do 50
billion dollars of gold
in less than a week i mean and
if you i mean you can really accumulate
that right it trades 50 trillion dollars
in volume
a year right versus let's say three to
four trillion
in bitcoin all the other crypto
currencies
so in terms of trading volume uh
it's much bigger okay but gold
and i think a lot of people are missing
this um
is just now entering a new phase it is
just now
entering a bull market and i might even
argue
that this coming up is gold's
first bull market and i say this because
um and again i did a longer interview in
march on this it's on youtube
but i say this because we've never had
um uh we've never had zero rates or
negative real rates
uh for this long i think that the the
bond portion of all of these traditional
asset
managers portfolio okay has now become
irrelevant so let's just say
you have 200 trillion dollars in assets
out there or
even 100 trillion dollars owned by
pension funds insurance companies all
these guys
and they have these 70 30 portfolios
right so you're talking about 70
trillion
i'm sorry 70 percent uh in
uh yeah 70 trillion in in equity or
assets you've got
30 sitting in government bonds just in
that one cohort
right those bonds do not act as a hedge
to their portfolio anymore
they're sitting at 50 basis points right
they cannot go below zero
if we have a slowdown in the next few
years and the fed has to come in again
and take rates negative uh in the front
end and inject liquidity
um those bonds will not appreciate to
offset
declines on the asset side of the
portfolio
okay they're in big trouble and i've
saved this
on twitter i've said it you know a few
times that the biggest
question that people will have
traditional asset managers in the 2020s
to answer is what am i going to do with
all of those government bonds
or even like you know corporate bonds
that are that used to yield five that
are now yielding one and a half or two
because they've gone out the risk
spectrum
one of the things that they will do and
they have not done it yet
is to move into gold okay
and so i don't know even if you're aware
of this but the institutional
allocation to gold is less than two
percent
globally okay it cannot be over for gold
before had it has even started
so when you say bitcoin and gold can't
coexist
that makes no sense to me because the
move
into gold hasn't happened yet
the move into bitcoin will come after
that
and i know some people will say oh no
smart people will just jump over the
gold
step and they'll just go right to the
bitcoin right
well it's too early for that
and also you know the mentality of
people
in that traditional asset world
they're way far away from owning bitcoin
i mean i know
from uh when you were uh you know as a
private equity uh
slash vc investor you speak to some of
these institutions and there are many of
them
that are years and years away you know
we talk about the ones
who are allocating now uh you know uh
who who understand it now and oh the
institutions are coming
but it's it's the top one percent
right 90 of them still i just got a
message today
uh it's not a proven valid technology
how many times have you heard of that
so those people are sitting with all of
those bonds
okay and from 1980 until today
every time we've had a slowdown the
bonds
offset losses on their equities okay
for the first time ever that's over
and so why move to gold because they're
going to move five percent or 10 percent
of their portfolio to gold
because gold does not have a limit
on the upside when central banks are in
balance sheet expansion mode
why have so many institutions not put
assets like
historically rights over the last two
five ten years
why have they kept that allocation at
two percent or lower
it's actually it's i mean it's pretty
much zero for almost all of them
and then a few of them are like five and
five percent or whatever so it averages
out to like one or two
you know it's just like anything um
gold was pegged until 71 and
you know it did it didn't exist as a
market from 33 to 71
so it mean it didn't trade it was pegged
the 70s bull market in gold
was really just about a release from a
peg i wouldn't even say it was
you know no one it was a trading asset i
don't think that people thought of
maybe they thought they'd have a little
bit of it but remember it peaked in 1980
okay and went into a bear market for 20
years
gold price was declining for 20 years so
if there was somebody out there
who thought gold should be in your
portfolio and circa 1978
by 1988 he was you know he was
proven wrong or you know and even and
then by
1998 you know he was dead on the ground
and then in
2000 i think it was 2000 you had the
bank of england sell the complete low
um you know and and authority people
just completely gave up on it of course
then
you know with the rise of china gold
then sort of took on a different
uh you know took on a different
narrative i mean gold
gold like bitcoin um has different
narratives that drive it at different
times
uh it's it's incredible asset in that
way
um i would just say sort of historical
pre-election
uh again a big bear market and then
people
sort of having done really well in
equities right equities
you know went sideways from 68 to 83
basically
so you made no money in equities for 15
years
but then look since 1980 you've done
great and technology has come and
changed everything
um and you know and driven return to the
economy so people haven't
needed to look at gold right also in
america
americans are very comfortable with uh
equity and with their currency so we've
never really been forced to think about
non-dollar assets we've never had to
worry about inflation when the dollar
goes down
as it did from 2008 euro went from 80 to
160. people forget
the dollar lost you know uh you know
whatever
70 80 percent of its value against the
euro
um uh and has
you know over periods of time but it
didn't hurt us we saw it
you know the equity market benefited um
but like in foreign countries and
especially in the em
they do have currency problems right
they do have
weak monetary policy uh uh people who
you know do you know quasi-illegal
things do
you know do actively debase their
currencies so
for them gold is more a part of their
portfolio than for ours
uh i would say only the germans and the
swiss really historically
uh and then the chinese and the indians
um
but you know i just think amongst the
really big
portfolios globally you know there just
hasn't been an experience with it and
look even just as an example just look
on twitter how many
true truly smart gold advocates
are there you know there aren't there i
mean of the
you know i interviewed tom kaplan uh
you know uh and and uh john hathaway for
for raul uh q4 those are two super smart
gold guys
um you know they're also older people
right i mean you know john's in the 70s
tom is
you know is young still in his 50s but
you know the preeminent guys are still
very old and not sort of
out there getting the message out so
look i i think it's coming that's when
you say
something like why why has
why hasn't the world put five percent or
ten percent
i think there's just there's no mr gold
there's no
there's no morgan stanley of gold right
um i think that's i think that's it
there's not been an advocate like
imagine if gold had a guy like you the
way you advocate for bitcoin
and throw in michael saylor and some of
the other guys who are out there really
you know
banging the drum um gold doesn't have
anyone out there like that
uh yeah and and i guess as you think
about
um kind of a lot of these institutions
now are obviously seeing hey
central banks aren't playing around
right they're going to keep just
printing and printing money balance
sheets are going to continue to expand
there's going to be weaker currencies
around the world
one definitely is going to be hey we
should put gold in the portfolio but it
sounds like
you're bullish on both gold being out of
the portfolio
and also bitcoin just in different sizes
yeah i think i think that's right but i
also think it's for
different groups of people okay explain
that so
look i mean if you're if you're a retail
guy
uh and you know you're you're you're
you're passionate about bitcoin and
you know you think it's gonna change the
world as you know as i do
um i'm as bullish as any of those guys
uh out there pounding the table i'm just
not as as loud about it
i think you know you know you should
have some goal but you don't
you don't really need it the way that
larger investors really need gold now
and they don't have it because in their
portfolio
they have a big hole right so for them
they should have that five percent they
should have that 10
or even more and they're gonna have a
hard time getting the gold on
i mean i'm sorry getting the the bitcoin
on at some point in the future
when when bitcoin is you know a five
trillion dollar
uh asset yeah i think it it becomes
easier to handle maybe even two three
four trillion
um but we'll get into that i think
that's also uh it's it's an
intellectual leap that is very hard
for people to make and we can get into
that um
but they i think these things coexist
for a while
because they're both hedges to the fiat
system
right i don't think fiat is going away
anytime soon
governments central banks they're not
going away
i i just you know control
power they're not going to give all the
world's
uh elite uh they're not giving up
uh this power just because bitcoin is
going up 20 x right
it's just years and years so but if you
don't believe in what's going on
in the system you don't have a lot of
options
right so gold will remain
that an option right so another thing
just to touch on is that we don't really
have enough
liquid stores of value available in the
investment world
like remember i'm coming at this from
the investment perspective
you're coming at it from the tech
perspective
and saying gold is old tech yeah yeah
okay okay i i it is a little
but that's not the point the point is
you don't have a hedge to the existing
system at all look real estate now which
many people thought
you know was is getting crushed in the
cities i mean who even knows
i mean eventually you know we'll get
back to work in in that way but
it's not a great you know maybe over a
30-year period i guess it's a good store
of value i don't know
um i i don't really know real estate
that well
but and is your thought dan that when an
institution says hey look the central
banks are printing tons of money we've
got to get
some sort of hedge uh whether it's to
inflation
you know kind of a whole story do they
look
to an inflation hedge basket
and then pick individual assets within
the basket or do you think most of them
are looking for more of like
index like exposure to inflation hedges
like
how do you think about the allocation
decision well i
i think you try to find different things
that i mean if you're really that big uh
you you probably you know there's
certain equities that'll perform
uh you know well when gold performs you
know there are miners as well
there are other things i don't i mean
i'm not
managing a trillion dollar portfolio i
don't really
worry about that i have a you know i
have a very large percent of
dtap which is my own entity allocated to
gold and bitcoin
and i i see the two together for me
and i have more gold than i have bitcoin
um
but you know look increasingly the
bitcoin side is getting much larger
um because i i am as i say in my twitter
bio
and i am a hodler of gold of physical
and
and bitcoin i think um i i
um so when i say that each person has
different needs so gold is really
important
to this institutional world but they've
yet
to acknowledge it right you don't see it
in the allocations
yet people don't have don't have it the
language
of understanding gold is really still
just in its infancy for them
right that's why it this coexistence
ending it is is totally off base
because for these people it hasn't even
started yet
and that's why i keep saying gold and
bitcoin are like cousins
because you know it's a hard money asset
in a world where for the first time in
in my career
there has never been as clear an active
um a debasement of fiat ever
i mean in the last ever so what are you
gonna do
against that right historically a store
of value was like the yen
right or the swiss franc but no one's
buying the yen
anymore that's like 15 years ago
that's the problem is that there aren't
enough
safe haven options they're not enough
store of value options available to the
investor
and so saying that gold is going to go
away
even before it started like
it's except it's it's acceptance mode
right
like so let me do this i i want to i
want to walk through kind of step by
step
as to the thesis that i have as to like
where i get to hey they won't be
coexistence
and i want to try to pinpoint the point
at which we diverge in thinking because
i actually think we agree on
a whole lot yeah some point towards the
end there's this divergence and i want
to try to pinpoint that so
the way that i think about this is like
the legacy system the central banks like
there's a bunch of problems they're
going to debase currencies and
investors are going to flee to inflation
hedge type assets or store value assets
i think you and i see eye to eye on that
and
right we could literally talk for hours
and hours and hours about all the
problems
but we agree there right the second
thing is that
the solution uh or one of the the main
solutions is gonna be sound money
principles
right and i think that then where we get
to is like
gold is the analog application of those
sound money principles right you say hey
look i want the physical gold i'm gonna
get the gold i'm going to put it outside
the making system
and i have control over like an analog
asset that i can touch and feel
right but that's but that's me and you
agreeing on that
yes if you were to sit in a room with
more traditional
that hundred trillion dollars they may
not
they may not really explain
explain why they may not agree with that
well look they can see that it's
happening but they
they've they're looking at you know what
are their ranges range of opportunity
the the opportunity sets they're just
they've never
done it before the allocation even to
gold miners
gold it's not that big no one in that
room okay
i'll tell you this for sure is sitting
around and saying gold can be
four thousand in five six years from now
i say that to you and you're like yeah
that's reasonable right
the bitcoiners are more gold believers
than everyone else outside of the
bitcoin world
you see what i'm saying so if you come
into my world so
here i i run the investment committee
for an endowment
like as i do it on my you know as part
of my charitable
activity it's a 500 million dollar
endowment i've worked on it for 11 years
okay we have an institutional advisor
so we have an advisor who who who
advises over a trillion dollars in
assets all right
it has been extremely difficult over the
years for me to get them to let us have
some gold i mean
we finally did about 18 months ago we
went into gold they don't you know they
don't recommend
out front and center everyone needs some
gold because of currency debasement
and because bonds are at 50 basis points
they are
just now in the last six to 12 months
saying maybe you should entertain some
gold so
i'm seeing this from that perspective
i'm
in that right i'm really a you know
a hedge fund uh investor trader
entrepreneur but i i span the entire
realm as well as like a bitcoiner so i
go from
endowment manager to bitcoiner right
i love it by the way that endowment put
one percent of its portfolio
into bitcoin in q1 q2 19
last year so and then that took
we became the first uh it was uh
well the first endowment of its kind to
own bitcoin directly
yeah anyway my point is that so
being in that world none of those people
like are really saying what you've just
said to me
yeah you agree but so you and i see
gold as this analog application of sound
money principles and then i think we see
bitcoin as like this
digital application of sound money
principles right there's the scarcity
all that kind of stuff so when i look at
that i say
hey golden bitcoin right for for
literally for years now i've been saying
gold in bitcoin or sound money
principles was the analog application or
the digital one
will end up both doing what right kind
of what what uh your position is
only recently have i changed my mind
and here are the things that i'm
starting to think through
so if you look at some of the gold
right there's gold etf outflows
on a very small basis over the last
couple of weeks or months
i mean yeah but that's just flow i mean
of course right so so there was a
massive rise and you would expect that
everyone's going to hold all the gold
forever and keep buying right so it
doesn't just kind of go up into the
right forever there's going to be kind
of these
uh it always goes up and down of course
so that was kind of one two then is some
of the central banks
right have actually been a net seller of
gold uh on a very small basis again and
and only in the short term right this
isn't a long term trend this is just
recently
so as i started to think through this i
started to say
when these asset allocators look for
those sound money principles
the big question i think is are they
going to
allocate across the analog application
and the digital
or are they going to pick one or the
other what
i've become convinced of in the first
scenario if they pick both
then you and i are correct and like both
do well right
what i'm starting to become more
convinced of it was kind of the
the impetus for that piece was wait a
second they may only pick
one and if they do i actually think they
pick the digital version
not the analog version over a long
period of time not enough
in the next three four five years i'm
talking over 30 the moment
they can't right at the moment they
can't
and so and i agree
it's too it's too much of a leap what i
was trying to say before was that
they're you're so far ahead you don't
realize it
the goal is i completely agree in the
short term you've been accepted
in the institutional circles yet
right they're gonna say we need to hedge
for the next five
years to replace our bonds
right they can't go in and do 30 billion
of bitcoin
they just can't do it and it would be
irresponsible to own
10 or 20 of all the bitcoin outstanding
and they'll drop the price up a lot it
just doesn't make sense
before they get to a 5 to 10 allocation
in gold
it will be years okay
years so that's why now if you're
telling me
in 50 years from now
people will have more bitcoin than gold
i mean
i think sure it could be
hold maybe one second hold on one second
because i'd play that thought out as
well
reading your piece i said so 50 years
from now
i have a different thought than you do
okay this is what i want to hear is what
do you think happens over here
50 years from now every single
asset will be on the blockchain every
financial asset
whether it's on you know the bitcoin
network or whether something in the
future happens or whatever it is
i i don't know um but everything will be
digital
every everything of extreme value
right we love bitcoin because of its
intense security
it's unhackable if you want to do you
know for large transactions
eventually the collateral of the system
everything we agree on all of that
okay the one thing is that
maybe in that time 50 years from now
there might actually be a premium
for physical gold because it won't be on
the blockchain
physical gold will be physical it won't
be tracked
so you forget everything every bitcoin
everyone knows every where it's it's
completely
known and the tax authorities are also
going to know
and governments are going to know and
everyone's going to know
okay but they're not going to know on
gold okay
and they still don't know on gold and
physical gold i'm talking about forget
etf and futures and all that
there might be a premium because 50
years from now physical gold will be the
only liquid
asset that is not digital now some of it
will be digitized
you know like the pax gold token could
have a 50 billion on it eventually or
whatever it is
um but that
to me also in my mind is like
i think that physical gold is completely
anonymous if you want it to be
and physical gold is not considered a
security
also so the regulations around physical
gold
and the taxation principles are
different
there is a chance that in the future
when bitcoin becomes an established
thing and everyone has it and it's
trading at four or five hundred thousand
you know government may say yeah we want
a tax you guys have made
10 billion dollars we're going to text
bitcoin to 50
right it's they'll know it there'll be a
record of it
physical gold is different and i'll tell
you why
and this isn't about evading taxes
that's a no i'm not talking about that
there are different taxation laws for
physical in different jurisdictions as
an example
in the uk if you are a uk citizen
you can buy their sovereign coins okay
the uk sovereign coins
and they're pretty liquid and pay no tax
ever
no capital gains no income no wealth no
inheritance nothing
they're grandfathered in zero tax
forever
so that's a nice way yeah i know that's
that's one thing
there are many things like that around
the world for
physical gold okay i'm not going to get
into them
but because it's an old asset um
because in certain places they try to
encourage
uh ownership of gold again that can
change but remember in 50 years from now
uh there could be that premium
right because it'll be something that is
not known
if you want it to be not known right so
that's
uh you know that's something you should
think about i mean i i don't think it it
plays into any
you know any anything that impacts my
decision making
um because i think it's still early for
both assets
absolutely and so when you think about
kind of the asset allocation
whether it's for maybe we'll do a retail
investor and then a large institution
between bitcoin and gold if somebody
called you up and they say hey you know
i've got some money
in my personal account what do you
suggest that allocation or what do you
see people doing there
and if a big institution called how do
you see that asset allocation between
bitcoin and gold
yeah i mean look uh i think institutions
should have somewhere between five and
ten percent in gold
and then i kind of use a like a three to
one ratio
um you know that's what that's what i so
if you have
if you have ten percent in gold three
percent of bitcoin
um if you're a retail person depending
on your age
like i think you can have you know you
could have 20 in bitcoin if you're a 30
year old
uh guy uh zero in bonds
like zero you should not own any bonds
at all
zero so i think um
yeah i mean i think you know but
everyone has different risk appetite
it's hard to say i mean i've heard you
say you're
80 in bitcoin or whatever it is you know
i
again i i i that's uh i really am from
sort of the the drunken miller camp
of i like to put all my eggs in one
basket and then watch that basket very
carefully
um that's just a macro you know a macro
guy
uh a focus um you know i want to be in
the fastest horse
so my guess is is look i think bitcoin
outperforms gold tremendously there
could come a point
you know maybe not too far in the future
where my bitcoin and gold is the same
right because i'm not trade growth yeah
yeah yeah and i um i think
i like wences casaurus is you know one
percent
for institutions to dip their toe in so
i think at the very beginning they
should have one percent
and then it increases with comfort um
but if someone just calls me up randomly
they're
you know uh 40 years old and
uh they have no bitcoin they want to buy
i just saved five percent
i also like this exposure and you're
probably not aware of this i'm launching
a fund
uh at the end of next month called 10t
and i have a bunch of partners
and we're buying uh private equity
stakes
uh in mid to late stage companies in the
digital asset ecosystem
so some of the companies that even that
you own
i would own you know let's say figure i
know you've been a big proponent i think
that
that's a fantastic company to own um
you know kraken and paxos right now or
doing raises
uh you know i think those are two
excellent companies
so i would uh i so after my uh bitcoin
exposure
i say to people i have would have half
in bitcoin and then
half in this type of a fun
infrastructure
yeah because i do believe that um you
know
central bank currencies whether you like
them or not they're coming
um you know d5 stable coins that entire
world whatever you think about it or not
uh there is going to be a world where
everything will be digitized and there
are companies
that are facilitating that and
um and also actually facilitating
commerce
um it's not just you know the trading
volumes it's
actual commerce that will be um
completely digitized so i think that
that for me
is is is also a chunk of that exposure
um and i think as some of these
companies come public
people will start to allocate to some of
these businesses
you know coinbase might be an ipo right
in q1
um i think and we've yeah go ahead
and i was going to ask how do you think
about um
gold bitcoin and that infrastructure so
it tends to be when bitcoin's price
rises obviously a lot of the
infrastructure companies do really well
as well
because there's just more trading
volumes the price goes up all that kind
of stuff
how do you think about kind of this
recent short-term divergence between
gold and bitcoin right around like the
correlations and things like i see
i i don't think you can trade this thing
look i've followed markets and traded
markets for years
and you know there's a lot of time and
brain damage that's that's done with
people trying to figure out
you know day-to-day moves and this thing
move and that thing didn't
this is this is much bigger than that i
mean bitcoin
um you you know i don't think you can
trade it i think there's too much risk
that you miss
you know a thousand point move at one in
the morning
and it never comes back you know or a
you know the
it all the all the math and studies have
shown
you really get paid when you hold this
thing
uh it's up 250 percent annualized for
the last 10 years
why would you ever trade it right and
you have two massive down years so
i don't i i believe you know people can
do what they want
and if you're 26 years old and you know
you love you know the action
and you're kind of a gambler and you
want to trade bitcoin that's great
i mean that's great but in terms of
building
wealth uh in bitcoin and gold as well
it's just not you know you're not going
to make that money at the end
and i don't want to pay short-term
capital gains tax
right you want to pay the as long you
know you want to pay that long-term
capital gains tax rate so
uh you know that that plays into this
too right
if you all that trading you're paying
you know you're paying uh
income i mean rates it's crazy um
i i couldn't agree more help me
understand
in terms of the sentiment right now
you're hearing from the institutional
world uh around uh gold and bitcoin it
sounds like you're bullish on that
sentiment being more open to adding
exposure to gold and you think that'll
kind of continue
uh in the coming years and then what
about bitcoin in terms of same there
just on a smaller scale
no i i don't think people are there i
mean like
you know as i said uh i i've been
speaking to a lot of institutional
investors
um about this this fund that i'm
launching of course you talk about
bitcoin a lot
uh when you talk about digital asset
ecosystem and the
as you call the the infrastructure
around uh
around it and you know there's there are
a lot of
a lot of people out there who who won't
even discuss it
so they're just like we don't believe in
crypto
is their comment and they haven't they
haven't done the work they don't know
what the white paper is they don't know
you know they don't they don't know um
even look
honestly even um
you know even someone like i was
listening to druck on cnbc
and he says look it's a store of value
for millennials
and for uh people in silicon valley
and they're making a lot of money and i
think you know it's a it's a good bet in
that way
um he didn't come out and say i believe
this is a great store of value
he didn't come out and say you know this
is the security network this is the
money protocol for the internet he
didn't say any of those things
so my guess is he's not he's not even
really
committed in a big big way not like
michael saylor
i mean he's he's unbelievable i mean you
know
fantastic that he's getting out there
every single day that he's bought 600
million dollars of bitcoin
i mean he's he's a huge shot in the arm
uh for the space um you know i think
we're all just grateful to have him
but again he comes from a technologist
background he's not
he's not from the investment background
now he's thinking about things an
interesting way
he thinks about inflation and
depreciation of his assets and
he has his hurdle rate is 15 because
in a way u.s equity kind of functions as
u.s fiat right and so
he's like well if if fiat is being
debased at a dollar could go down 15
a year for five or six years i'm
assuming
you know the equity will continue up i'm
losing my purchasing power
so i mean i think he thinks about it
that in the right way
but that is very innovative that is not
normal
right and if you have even someone like
a druck and some of the other
guys not quite all in like that
i mean 600 million is a really i mean
that is one
that's a big statement right to do that
now it's not like
the winklevoss who've had you know a
billion plus
or whatever for years and years and
there are a handful of guys
like that this is a guy who allocated it
basically
you know now right so it's you know at
ten thousand
um you know it's a very powerful
statement and his reasoning i think is
is phenomenal
um but he also attacks gold and he says
it's
dangerous to think about gold and
bitcoin together
and that's actually not right i mean
maybe within the framework of a
of a tech uh in a tech
a background person but if you are an
investor
okay you haven't come to the conclusion
most that you've come to yet many have
some have but again you're just seeing
the smartest guys
in the world coming to it now tudor's
piece was just last summer
it didn't come out five years ago druck
was just
on cnbc last week those are the smartest
guys in the space in the world
right and dalio he's not even there yet
he wants to be he wants to be taught
he's asking you on
you know twitter maybe you know you and
you and saylor sit him down i mean
so and he is at the cutting edge
apex really of that traditional world
so that just shows you how far away
they're not even there yet they don't
even know how to think about it yet
so i just i have like a different
perspective
and i don't think it's dangerous to
think about gold and bitcoin
i think that gold in a way i don't want
to say it's like the gateway drug
to bitcoin because but it kind of is the
gateway
and it seems obvious to you but
it's not really that yeah
how do you think about stock the flow
obviously that's been a very popular
uh thing in the gold world or used in
the gold world previously
uh and now has been um kind of applied
to bitcoin
uh is that something that in the gold
world you put
uh kind of weight on um or do you really
look i mean i i i think it's fine i like
it i
uh he has an rsi that he puts out
a relative strength index in connection
with his model
you know a hundred trillion and the the
stock to flow model
that i think is great because when it's
low
that's when you're supposed to buy when
it's high you're supposed to sell but
it works over years and it's had a very
good tracking we're right in the middle
now
and i think i put a tweet out last week
about it so i like it
but in some ways it's a relatively i
don't want to say simplistic model
um there's a lot more that goes into
making decisions about
assets so yeah i look at that but i also
look at 50 other things before making a
decision
um and i look at the gold uh uh
where gold is on and i'm like yeah i'm
aware of that
but you know drilling down into supply
demand
mechanics of gold is probably is a lot
more important
you know we don't have a lot of gold
coming online
i don't want to say we have peak gold
but supply will decline over the next
you know three four years and that just
tells me that price is going to have to
go up a lot to encourage
a lot more exploration
and um and excavation so
i i like it but it's just one input and
i i think people in the bitcoin space
again a lot from a technologist
background
aren't used to doing the deep deep
50-page
analysis on an investment you know which
is normally what we do you know i
you know and ordinarily i would have you
know between
four and eight research analysts will
spend months
writing uh a presentation or an
idea out before taking a position
that's months of digging it's not just
here's the model
we're going to buy i mean no one does
that
in the no one who's long for this world
does that right so
it's just a nice input i think he he got
attacked a little bit recently i just
it's because you know eventually
there'll be
a lot more work like that i think nick
carter does tremendous work
i mean i agree more tremendous work um
you know so i yeah let's talk a little
bit about twitter before i let you go
just in terms of twitter is where uh
kind of the the
community is where the conversation is
uh you mentioned earlier this idea of uh
privacy and how privacy used to be a big
thing but is
quickly not becoming a big thing in the
investment world talk a little bit about
this
well no no no i yeah i think look
as i said i think you know in the first
20 years of my career you basically
as i said you you know you'd get fired
for talking to the press and people
didn't talk to the press and
uh it just you just didn't you focused
on your ideas
and your portfolio and you know and
moved on
but i think that i think that's sort of
a very
you know almost it's it's it feels to me
old
and archaic i try to move away from
things that are old uh because they
don't evolve
and you know the the
the concept of complete 100 privacy
uh i i i just i don't want to say i see
it going away
but it's just that look there's you get
you get quite a benefit from these
interactions as well
uh so you have to give up a little bit
of privacy
um look metcalf's law is something real
and here's something that um investment
guys
macro investment guys especially don't
really get as much
like they don't really get the network
value
for instance of bitcoin like it doesn't
really make sense like where's the cash
flow
well there's no cash flow but but the
network is expanding at
a crazy fast rate right so it's the sort
of the same thing with
bitcoin i mean with twitter i mean i
guess the the hive mind concept
that you know you get
so much from interactions again 50
70 of it you know can be garbage but 10
20
of it is really good and there are
people out there
um you know who may not necessarily be
you know well-known
fund managers or even necessarily that
successful but who can have
great ideas and so this is a forum
you know this is a forum for that um
just i i don't i don't know the old the
old guys
are just i i i think they're just
uncomfortable
giving up a little bit of that privacy
and
i think the benefits are great and also
it's becoming a little
weird to be a hermit you know i mean
even uh if you're it's just weird if you
don't have
you know if you're not on any social
media anywhere
people think you're hiding something or
even though you may not be
um so anyway i
i like i like the interaction lots of
smart people from all over the world who
you'd never get to interact with
um and you know i i just
i i uh make liberal use of that uh of
that blocking function as well
because i don't really like cursing or
personal attacks
or people who are too emotional about
all this
i like you know it just life's too short
and i like to read my
threads i like them to be clean i like
to go back and look at them
you know uh you know have conversations
sometimes with
some people's comments so you don't want
a lot of
you know yeah
right i mean you know some people like
it i
yeah absolutely before i let you go
let's talk a little bit just about uh
when you zoom all the way out and you
see
gold and bitcoin um and kind of the
institutional world
what is your maybe not prediction but
just what's your sense of like how this
plays out
we you know let's go 10 years from now
do
majority of institutions have exposure
to gold
and 20 percent have exposure to bitcoin
uh
and they're at that kind of ten percent
and three percent you mentioned
like how do you think this plays out
let's say through the 2020s where do we
end up
um i think we'll get to a place
so you're saying 10 years from now i
mean this is hard i look i think we get
to a place where
people have between you know these big
institutions call it
i could see 10 percent in in gold and
five in bitcoin
and some might reverse that the more
speculative
uh guys who are used to investing in uh
venture capital as well
you know they could have maybe ten
percent uh fifteen percent
um you know it'll eat away a little bit
of people's equity
allocations and a little bit at um you
know and of course the bonds will be at
zero
so um you know that's a huge
huge chunk i mean 15 of
uh you know 100 trillion right is 15
trillion
that could be 15 trillion to flow
to flow into um or more i mean i think
it'll eventually be more because
look for me bitcoin we didn't talk about
this but i
is much bigger than gold all right
bitcoin is you know
it could be and i i think will be that
value
protocol for the internet gold is a
store of value
bitcoin is an entire network
right one aspect of what bitcoin is is a
store of value
that's another reason i don't understand
all the the constant comparisons to gold
because you're limiting what it is and
if you say to an investor oh it's just
digital
gold they're like no it's not and that's
it
but if you say to them this is an
invention akin to
the invention and discovery of
electricity or
the invention of the combustible engine
then they're like what are you talking
about it's just digital gold you said
no it's not that's one little aspect of
what bitcoin
is so i think that
people in the space who harp on this
comparison
are you know at least for the bigger
investment world
they're not telling the story the right
way this satoshi's white paper
solved the byzantine generals problem
that's a big deal
no one else was able to solve that
problem the mechanics of how bitcoin
works is very complex but it's an
unbelievable creation gold
is not that creation gold is important
as in the investment world as a store of
value and a hedge against the fiat
bitcoin is bigger than you know it could
be a system that grows up that's
equal in size to the entire
legacy system so
i don't know why people don't focus
on that aspect more the
you know the the the collateral for the
new system
right the i mean all of those bigger
things like the security look
it turns what have we had that turns
energy
into security right gold doesn't turn
gold actually does turn a little bit of
energy into
security because it takes a lot of
energy to produce a bar of gold
and gold is very secure you know brinks
vaults have never been
violated i mean it's a lot more secure
than i think the bitcoiners understand
but look it's not this unbelievable
almost like
machine this mechanism okay investors
don't get there because they stop at oh
it digital well
maybe but maybe not if they were to
understand what it
actually is right
this bulletproof security truth
mechanism
you know you know i have real estate
investors especially coming to me
trying to understand this because they
think you know you probably see this
with some of your companies
they think that um
eventually all the transactions that get
done
you know are put on some blockchain or
are put on the bitcoin network or
however
you know i mean that would be
transformative
there's a 100 200 100 trillion in in
real estate assets around the world
imagine if you know that we're all on
the bitcoin network
i'm just saying you can't do that with
gold
right gold is not that so you know
bitcoin is much bigger
it's a much bigger thing it's a very
nuanced i'm gonna ask you this question
okay why do guys in the space
not push that message
out there i obviously i can't speak for
everybody
i do think that uh one is um there's a
group of people who don't believe that
right i'm with you i believe it but i
think what shall they believe
what don't they believe i think there's
some people who literally just think
it's digital gold and they talk about it
that way right now maybe that's a small
group but there's definitely some people
who just think that
then there's a group of people who
believe kind of wait wait a second
anthony hold on a second because
there aren't even that many people who
really believe in gold
and so you're telling me that guys are
like
okay it's digital gold and that's it
and there and then they move on well i
think
put in that bucket i think what ends up
happening is there's a lot of people who
would have been
gold bugs right like like a a group of
people who
naturally would they're just much
younger and so they hear bitcoin right
okay and so like again it may be a small
group but there's definitely that group
then there's a group of people who have
a belief in that bigger vision
but they're scared to talk about it so
what do they do is they basically just
say oh it's digital gold they explain it
on a smaller scale
because they think that the group that
they're talking to will
uh be more receptive to that right it's
kind of like if you walk in
and uh and you pitch amazon in 1994
and you say uh we're going to be the
largest company in the world everyone
goes good luck kid
right if you say we're going to sell
books on the internet i'll give you some
money for that right
right but on twitter people can voice
their opinions as they like
why doesn't this message get out there i
mean
antonopoulos and some things especially
these older youtubes he gets into this
the saffidin amus book he gets into sort
of a bigger vision
um you know there there are other books
and articles out there but
you know i don't you know i i don't
really get it because
it is that mechanism right it's the
functioning
you know figuring out how the minor is
working the node operators and
the this proof of work algorithm maybe
those words just scare people
i don't know yeah it's something part of
it and then i think that there's
actually a big group of people
who believe exactly what you just said
about like a really big opportunity
right and i'm one of them you're one of
them and all of that
because i think you hold a very nuanced
view right it's um it's a view of
uh gold and bitcoin will coexist bitcoin
will have a larger market cap over a
long period of time
but well gold market cap capital also
like 50 years from now yeah a very long
period of time
yeah yeah and then on top of that
that doesn't necessarily mean as
bitcoin's market cap grows
that gold's market cap goes down they
actually may grow in lockstep
well they will grow in lockstep and for
the next 10 years
many institutions have no alternative
they need this in their portfolio the
goal so
i think it's like growing together as
you
say for at least 10 years
uh you know at least i mean i
but bitcoin will be the fastest horse
yeah and look i think that that's
probably one of the most rational views
of
how this plays out uh especially over 10
years
right like i tend to think that that is
probably more right than wrong
uh and the big question is just gonna be
what's it take to get the
you know 800 billion dollar trillion
dollar asset managers to start putting
gold in there and
and uh and bitcoin as well right
i think it's i think it's more of the
same
you know this balance sheet expansion
you know moving to negative rates uh i'm
shocked that it's actually taken so long
to be honest because
europe and japan have had negative rates
uh you know you actually get paid to own
physical gold uh if you're borrowing at
that negative rate so there's no storage
fee at all um i'm just surprised it's
you know it's it's taking
this long for this wholesale adoption
but
look people get used to patterns
of behavior and get used to assets
and look uh price goes up helps in gold
too
right it's not it's not just a
bitcoin i love it all right i
asked the same question to everyone uh
two questions before
i wrap up and you'll get to ask me one
the first is what's the most important
book that you've ever read oh
god there are a few um
someone asked me about this recently
um
i should have uh
well a book that i recommended recently
to somebody
that is certainly in my top five is the
rebel by camus
why do you like that one yeah that i
mean it's it's sort of the best
uh you know intellectual history of
a western philosophy so i i did a bama
in history of brown
so i i've always sort of tended
towards history and philosophy and um i
think there's uh
a really great personal message there i
mean that book
um yeah that book's been very important
to me
yeah i love it second question is mike i
also like go ahead
no go ahead what was yours i'm gonna say
you know for the for this crowd though a
little more i mean
i also love the fountainhead um you know
that was a key book
when i was younger that i you know kind
of
you know there are aspects of that that
i love some not so much but i can
remember
uh that had a profound effect on me when
i was young too
so i love it second question is more fun
aliens
are you a believer or a non-believer
aliens uh yeah i think the probability
is there's something out there
i mean you know look uh
there are hundreds of billions of
galaxies right
hundreds of billions at some point some
molecules must have come together
you know just a probability yeah i i
just th the odds are there
uh it might take us another billion
years to know it
right i mean you don't know but
when you ask an open-ended question like
that i think the odds are
are there yeah i i agree with you
completely
what uh what one question do you have
for me to finish up
um how the hell do you
do all the stuff that you do
i just don't understand it i you're on
twitter it's
you know 2 a.m and then you write the
newsletter and that comes out and then
you're
you know you're you're involved in an
offering of uh you're just i i
i what's your workout regimen because
that's
that for me is what keeps everything
together
yeah so uh over time i've gotten hyper
efficient with my time and i basically
have like blocks on my schedule of i
know
okay now switch contacts like working on
this working on that
so that definitely helps uh from a
workout standpoint
um i have spent a ton of time trying to
optimize sleep
and right what i've found i have two
it's very important
yeah and what i found is uh working out
is the key to sleep
so what the way i think about it is like
i want to do enough physical activity
every day to tire myself
out so that i sleep well at night and
usually that can be anywhere between
like 35
to an hour and a half uh one of the
hacks in quarantine has been
uh every day every day yeah every day
you don't miss a day
i mean i might miss a day like here or
there randomly but but nothing i don't
try
uh to miss a day um but the other thing
that i've uh started doing that is
really helpful
is uh when i'm taking calls i'll go on
walks
so i may end up some days i may go you
know and have walked for two hours
outside
uh and then i'll come and i'll like
finish you know working out or whatever
yeah but you're not that all the guy to
be like going on walks i mean like you
could
what are you 37 38 39
32 you should be i mean walks i mean you
should be on the uh
on the treadmill hitting it hard or yeah
but if i'm on the [ __ ]
sweat yeah i guess you're right right
yeah yeah so when i'm not on the phone
i'm not going on walks but if i'm on a
phone call
basically it's a way to kind of be hyper
efficient with my time right get the
call done and also some physical
activities so
yeah it's uh it's not so you're you're
just multitasking through it
yeah exactly that's all yeah no no
i presume you see yourself in this
business for the next
you know 20 years having fun
yeah i know me too i i mean i think this
is going to be my focus for
you know the next 10 years plus this
world
i don't see and i don't see anything
with as much asymmetry to the upside
right nothing nothing right it's so
early still it's gonna be uh it's gonna
be fun that's for sure
where can i send people to find you on
the internet or find out well twitter
what you're working on just send them to
twitter yeah i mean dtap cap
uh i'm i'm not on linkedin
it's so funny i get like all these
requests every day but i don't do it
because
i was never a guy that did that i was
not a
going out meeting clients you know i was
an investor so
i just never got around to doing that uh
i know
twitter's way better twitter's with
linkedin anyways
of course i'm on bloomberg but you know
that sort of dates me right like i can't
live without my
it used to be bloomberg was the cutting
edge i used to transact over bloomberg
yeah i would just send it
a message and say you know buy this all
right today
right yeah i mean yeah so now it's all
twitter
all right my friend listen thank you
really good chatting
absolutely you are an absolute legend
and i appreciate the time we will
definitely have to do this again in the
future
yeah i love this i had some points i
didn't make that maybe i'll make next
time
and uh have a good thanksgiving and
congratulations
uh as a newlywed thank you very much
that's a lot of fun all right dan thank
you so much
see ya